Ronny is the worst speller in the world
and we were wondering could he be like a
just an ordinary sixth grader
so we asked Sal's son to come in and
southsun is going to challenge Ronnie to
a spelling bee let's meet a very cute
kid a nice kid
Sal's kid where is he Jason you've
gotten so fat you blocked the kick
completely out I couldn't see I gotta
tell you man what's up buddy hey Aaron
you're in 6th grade and we wanted to see
how Ronnie would perform against it we
all know your dad Sal he's been working
on the show for a long time do you know
what South does here your dad he he told
me like you usually like write jokes
like he's on the show sometimes I can
stuff like that did you notice well
Aaron Ronny yeah how well there's a
couple of ways of spelling some people
spell it a RR Oh N I think you're gonna
be I think you're gonna be Ronnie my
money's on you good Aaron is a know some
people spell it that way today RR oh and
like actually seen someone actually
alright you know everybody knows
everything
that's all right Aaron Ronnie it's time
to play spell EB
[Music]
so you sit there right on the card why
not but what's the difference right
Ronnie what's this
I couldn't stand through the whole game
anyway all right fellas who wants to go
first
Ronnie or doesn't matter I guess I'll go
you'll go first V E
g-e-t a B L e vegetable that is correct
all right Ronnie
your turn okay and your word is a fourth
grade level word okay
your word is penguin yeah that's a
fourth grade book yeah it is fourth
grade level word you laughed iron right
because that's an easy one right yeah
it's it's pretty easy P D and G UI n
Ronnie that's correct
I'm gonna ask Aaron now this is a real
battle the word is several s
the word is predator p r e d a itor I'm
sorry Ronnie that's one right out and
shaking his head predator predator p r e
d EI t o r that is Perez now you are now
ahead three two one
[Applause]
predator 3 2 1 yes right and then you
don't worry all right all right don't
try to keep score too let's get off the
fourth grade words will go to physical
PHY know what I'm sorry is psy H icao
right and you're laughing at Ronnie you
must know uncle Ronnie got that one
wrong he got the first all right trying
physical ok PHY s I see al that is
correct Ron
[Music]
by the way in case anyone's wondering
we're sending Ronnie to summer school
all right how's this
Ronnie February the month February you
want me to use in a sentence this one
you're gonna get right I'm gonna get you
back on the scoreboard I'm gonna help on
piranha fvb
are you ary you got a right Ron yeah
okay
you're on the board two to four Wow all
right okay Aaron faculty F a see you LT
what that's correct
very nice could you got that one right
no five to do in Aaron's favor
all right you ready yeah receipt re c e
IP t you got that right intelligence yes
yes t e l i g ance all right Ronnie you
go this is a chance to steal
yeah okay all right intelligence I and
he I'll be like you i said ii l l
i G ENC we got a right put your head
with you next about that Aaron Caravan
balloons over the caravan see ya o VN
Ronny steel
Ronnie you get this we got a tie score
go ahead see good
hey go ahead
avian that's correct Ronnie you're tied
with the small child everyone calm down
the battle is fierce Ronnie actually
Terrans turn Myron you could win it here
are you ready yeah all right Museum
museum yes mm go ahead you yes s II um
that is correct
Ronnie should get a shot all right
Ronnie yes here we go
ultimatum ultimatum ultimatum common
word you go ahead L yes T a M
a TI um clothes embarrass yourself it's
you LTI mhm
um always have with the I crap
I'm gonna tell you something Ronnie you
have nothing to be ashamed by you are a
an exceptional young man and you've got
you know taking on a guy this elderly is
difficult you know what I mean you had a
disadvantage and you took on the task
anyway and for all of us here at the big
Spelling Bee I want to say I do
[Music]